قالت هيئه عمليات التجاره البحريه
البريطانيه انها تلقت تقريرا عن وقوع حادث
في محيط باب المندب حيث انفجرت طائره
مسيره قرب سفينه على بعد 45 ميلا بحريا
جنوب غرب الصليف باليمن دون وقوع اي اضرار
وفي تحديث اخر ابلغت الهيئه عن انباء بشان
وقوع حادث ثان فوق سفينه على بعد حوالي 50
ميلا بحريا غرب مدينه الحديده اليمنيه
واضافت الهيئه ان عده تقارير اشارت الى
رصد طائره مسيره تحلق على ارتفاع منخفض
فوق السفينه قبل ان تنفجر على بعد ميل
ونصف ميل بحري من السفينه وان السلطات
تحقق وفي حدث اخر قالت شركه امبريا
البريطانيه للامن البحري ان سفينه تجاريه
تابعه لاسرائيل تعرضت لهجوم بطائره مسيره
في بحر العرب قباله الساحل الغربي للهند
ما ادى الى نشوب حريق
واضافت انه تم اخماد الحريق الذي اندلع
على متن السفينه وافادت وكاله الانباء
الهنديه ان الناقله كانت تحمل نفطا خاما
من السعوديه وترفع العلم الليبيري دون
وقوع اصابات بين افراد الطاقم واشارت الى
ان الحادث وقع على بعد 200 كيلومتر جنوب
غربي رافال بالهند وهو اول هجوم معروف حتى
الان بعيدا عن البحر الاحمر منذ حرب
غزه
هذا وقالت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه ان
الهجوم الذي استهدف السفينه المرتبطه
باسرائيل قباله سواحل الهند تم بواسطه
طائره مسيره اطلقت من الاراضي الايرانيه
وليس من قبل الحوثيين واظهرت صور بثت على
منصات التواصل الاجتماعي الاضرار التي
لحقت بالسفينه قبل ان ينجح طاقمها في
اخماد النيران من جانبها نفت شركه زيم
الاسرائيليه علاقتها بالسفينه حسب ما ذكرت
الق الثانيه عش
الاسرائيليه